[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he was born Edison Aransas
but the world do him simply as Pele he
was regarded by many as the greatest
football player of all time small strong
and exceptionally gifted Pele played for
the famous Santos club in Sao Paulo at
the age of 15. the Brazil National Side
by 16 and by 17 he'd won the World Cup
scoring two goals in the 1958 final
against host Sweden
injury hampered His World Cup in Chile
four years later but he still played a
part in Brazil's Triumph again and by
1970 in Mexico pele's star was still in
the century as he provided Unforgettable
memories on the way to the World Cup
victory number three
before he hung up his boots his Stardust
was used to try and ignite soccer in the
United States with the New York Cosmos
by this time Pele the brand had taken
over and product endorsements were as
prolific as his goal scoring
he was an instantly recognizable Global
Ambassador and his personal life was
equally colorful married three times and
divorced and with seven children he is
claimed to have fathered more his son
was sentenced to 33 years in prison in
Brazil for money laundering one of the
biggest debates in sport is whether he
was better than Argentinian Legend
Maradona who himself died in 2020. in
the year 2000 FIFA awarded them both
joint player of the century
but Pele was unique his name is almost
synonymous with football he died in Sao
Paulo after losing his battle against
cancer
but for Brazilians he will always be
remembered as a hero who gave them and
the world such Joy with a football at
his feet